it's the astros and the rays
and we've arrived here to a game seven
it is charlie morton and the tampa bay
rays and he is their best big game
pitcher ronnie well charlie morton is
undefeated with the raise in the
postseason and he is the only pitcher
with three wins in a post-season winner
take all games
into center field
kevin who is back after missing three in
a row
puts it away for out number two two up
two down for charlie morton michael
brantley he's riding a 10 game hitting
streak right now charlie morton
that's been great as bradley goes to the
opposite field of base head
keeps on hitting that's 11 in a row
lance mccullers gets this game seven
start for the asteroid you can see what
he's done uh in relief and then starting
in the past in game sevens mccullers was
outstanding in game two seven innings no
walks 11 strikeouts those two games
piggybacking
with charlie morton at 17 and his first
pitch hits margot randy a breakout star
here in october but he's been doing it
for the rays since he was brought up in
early september six home runs in the
postseason now the two-two pitch swing
at a drive high in the air right center
field springer to the wall it's gone
a two-run homer here in the first for a
rose arena and the rays have a
two-nothing lead in game seven randy
rosarina does it again
what a ride he is on
randy arose arena with his seventh home
run this post season guys that is a new
rookie record in the postseason rosa
reina is on another level knew it all
the way
alex bregman leads off it's two to
nothing tampa bay on a randy rose arena
home run two balls one strike morton out
of the window the right-hander pitches
ground ball back through the middle
diving as willy adams gets there behind
the back throws to first he got him
out number one
a gorgeous play by willie adams taking a
hit away from alex bregman
wow
what a play by william thomas
mike zunino race catcher first time he's
hit eighth in this postseason he's been
doing damage out of the nine spot cenino
waits in the breaking ball drilled in
the air to deep left field this one's on
its way and it's three nothing raised a
solo homer from mike zenino from owen
two to a full count and the rays extend
their lead to three-nothing but we've
seen him this postseason when he hits it
it's a long way sometimes you can make
up for your regular season doing exactly
what cenino's done added here in the
fourth facing jose altuve
i wasn't even thinking that way there's
a swing of the miss and down he goes
charlie morton picks up strikeout number
three
brought away here in the fourth
[Applause]
bradley pops it up
[Applause]
and charlie martin
retires altuve and bradley got him with
a cut fastball that time
struck out his first time because
there's a pitch that strike three called
over the outside corner at 95.
beautifully received by cenino and lance
sparksdale with the ring up of carlos
correa who didn't like it
three up three down go the astros here
in the fourth
well this move by dusty maker will
certainly be up for discussion lance
mccullars saying to dusty who's walking
to the mount he can't swing he can't
swing and he's talking about kevin
kiermeier and lance mccullers is out
three and two thirds innings
three earned runs on the board he
finishes with seven strikeouts and a man
at first right now it's up to rayleigh
to try to get out of the setting
and down he goes fastball up and then
kier meyer is gone and it's quickly no
balls and two strikes on reddick
[Applause]
and renika swinging a atomos
upstairs with a fastball
14 in a row for charlie morton astros
have not had a
base runner reach second base yet there
he goes
slow rolling third base window coming in
gloves
keeps it in front
but springer on his way to third
that'll be an infield hit jose altuve is
aboard and the tying run coming to the
plate kevin cash is coming to the mound
charlie morton is finished for the night
absolute brilliance on the mount nick
anderson is coming on and he'll be
facing bradley with 10 outs to get he
pitches ground ball right to second base
routine low's got it he throws him out
and the razor nine outs away nick
anderson gets michael bradley and the
shutout is intact he's got a runner at
third base with one out in the sixth
inning they're at the corners now the
two one doesn't eno swinging a high fly
ball into deep left center field
springer going back to the base of the
wall and he makes the catch but the sac
fly will happen as troy tanks and scores
and the rays have a four nothing lead
now here come the astros two on one out
and julie gorilla coming up with runners
leading at the corners of the pitch
here's the swinging grounder towards
short could be two willie flips the
second out turn to first double play
it goes six to four to three nick
anderson's best friend and the astros
are turned aside again it's gonna be
pete fairbanks astros putting up a
threat here in the eighth base is loaded
and the astros will bring correa to the
plate as the tying run oh my goodness oh
what a scenario for dusty baker there is
one extra arm available for kevin cash
tonight in that bullpen that he wouldn't
have in a normal scenario that's tyler
glass now
their big hard throwing starting pitcher
fairbanks delivers
and correa grounds it through the right
side that's a base hit diaz will score
altuve around third and coming home he
will score as well a two-run single for
carlos correa and it is 4-2 tampa bay
the tying run is aboard brickman has
just the one hit with first and second
the one-two pitch swing and a miss
he
struck him out bregman goes down and
fairbanks finally takes care of an astro
here the moment of truth has arrived
fairbanks on the mound in the ninth in
game seven of the alcs and a swing gotta
miss he struck him out
99 mile an hour fastball
now it's reddick 4-2 rays tying run at
the plate for the astros with one way
takes a big deep breath and pitches
swing at a miss he struck him out the
rays are one out away tying run is at
the plate and diaz has power no shifts
here for the raise loud to the right of
second in the pitch swinging up pop fly
shallow right charging margaux he is
under it and the tampa bay rays have
just won the american league planet for
the second time in franchise history the
rays are on their way to the world
series fireworks in the sky the
celebration explodes out of the first
base dugout and the rays for the second
time ever will play in the fall classic